hey everyone i'm alana and welcome to my
channel pretty sure this video is
terribly lit
today i am like overwhelmingly
excited to the extent that it's a little
bit cheesy
like i'm sort of emotional about it i'm
not proud of it
to be unboxing the cyberpunk 2077 xbox
one x
it's super limited edition and sold out
very very quickly and i didn't get one
and so i never thought that i would have
the opportunity to do
what i'm doing today and um yeah just
yep pretty stoked
but there is a whole story about how i
got this which i will tell you guys
after i unbox it so we can cut to the
chase for the people who just want to
see
the thing being opened but as part of
that because i don't feel deserving of
this
i'm also going to be giving away two
xbox one x's and i will also share
details a little bit later about
how you can get one of those if you like
okay
i don't have a good unboxing setup if
you're new to my channel welcome
if you've been here for a while you
already know that okay
first thing out of the box we have
this beautiful cyberpunk 2077
xbox one controller i actually thought i
would give it a shout to this because i
only posted it on my instagram story i
just recently got this
this is a limited edition wonder woman
controller for 1984 the upcoming movie
that's i guess dc
made how pretty is that back to
cyberpunk
let's open it up shall we
[Music]
yes dude whoa so this one has arasaka
branding on it
it's also got literally etched into it
it says no
future like that's actually properly
etched in on the back obviously we've
got our samurai logo
feels great can confirm is a controller
it definitely has um
more like indentation than any other
controller i own like it literally
has lines that feel like dug into it um
this part particularly which is
definitely unique next up we have two
xbox pro charging stands um i don't own
any of these
i just use cables for all of my
controllers i just i don't
mind playing wired so i just plug
everything in unplug occasionally when i
want to play wireless
damn this is heavier than i expected
very cool
a little charging dock there that just
hit your controller on top of let's grab
it boom
that is a nice all right
obviously we also have cables love
cables huge fan of cables
now for the console itself
look at that big old v and obviously
this is what the xbox is actually gonna
look like
yeah i think it it will be the most
obnoxious xbox i own
and i say that as someone who owns two
of the taco bell
xbox one x's but yeah pretty standard
box
xbox one x one terabyte
all the expected stuff let's open it up
we are on to box two i don't even think
i want to throw this box out do you know
how many boxes i have in this apartment
there's like around the corner back
there where i've got my batman
right next to that in this direction is
a coat closet
it has some dresses and a few coats and
mostly just
boxes for all of those batman statues
since i have a box problem nice that's
what she said nice but
look at it another beautiful box and
like the back
has what looks like some cyberpunky
street art very cool
damn this presentation is so good so
this is first up gonna be cable box
it's got more graffiti on it definitely
heavily samurai inspired
whoa what all right
teal hdmi cable okay bro that's
as extra as hell we've got our second
controller in here
absolutely beautiful regular power cable
nothing exciting
not teal again more just
beautiful boxes hot damn this one is
going to be a console stand i believe
yep the stand for the xbox one x which
for this one
i actually won't be using i'll be laying
it on the side put that back together
the console itself uh ladies and
gentlemen
hello there's something very exciting
about unboxing a new console right now
because it puts in a perspective like
how close we are to unboxing next-gen
consoles which is
truly some of the most exciting of times
whoo baby
oh my gosh what this is so cool
dude it's so unique you can wait you
wait your turn let me look at it first
oh my god look i seen pictures of this
but i don't feel like
the textures of it really occurred to me
until i saw it like this in person you
know
so okay here we go the front of this oh
let's just move you out of the way but
just getting in the way there beautiful
and again these indentations you see are
real
that is a real indentation in the
plastic it's not just paint made to look
like different panels
same applies to this stuff all of these
lines are actually etched in
which i think is the part that i didn't
expect that i'm finding incredibly cool
it's also just
does a very good job of looking
aged and worn while also looking like
future tech uh very very very nice
the bottom is what i like the most
though check that out
it's like fully textured
um that's that's definitely real paint
which has glitter in it because of the
way that it's shining
i just especially for the part that you
won't see like
it's just so goddamn cool like they even
have little militech details like all
down the front
here the back is standard but still
colored so it's still like just blue on
this part
god damn dude
this is so rad and i'm putting it in
this setup here i don't know if i
mentioned that yet where i have my
i have one xbox one here that i
occasionally swap my xbox and my ps4 app
for streaming so this is going to become
my
streaming xbox one because i figure it
works because i have the cyberpunk chair
at this setup got my switch there so
it'll just sit next to that and i think
it's going to look beautiful
i have a cyberpunk background um have
for ages even before i got the chair
i'm very excited about cyberpunk if you
didn't know so then here is everything
together
absolutely beautiful work
this is
very uh glittery actually there's like
glitter in all of this paint
and it i love that they designed it so
it looked like militech made it
specifically
obviously the controller has got arasaka
on it um so it's even got like the
warring factions in the two pieces of
hardware which is just so cool
oh man um so to get to the story of how
i managed to get my hands on this
i'm gonna cut it short and there is a
letter included that i have read
um but i'm not gonna read that out in
case the person who sent it to me
doesn't want that to be broadcasted
basically when i did uh it was a very
long charity stream i think we streamed
for like eight plus hours to raise money
for
lebanon after the explosion someone was
in my chat being like if you hit the
goal i'm going to send this to you
and i kept saying please don't i don't
feel like i deserve this
please send this to someone who doesn't
already have an xbox one x
or um you know
is less fortunate than me who was
deserving of something this cool
um i kept being like please don't don't
please don't do it i will feel too
guilty
and i certainly still have some of that
so they managed to reach out to
a friend of mine uh who then delivered
it to
my house uh they reached out to what's
good games actually and then shipped it
to them who then delivered it to me
and when i found that out i was like man
i don't feel good about this
because i again don't feel like i
deserve it but then it was here
and uh i don't want to be parted with it
because i also really wanted one um and
i'm really
just so blown away
by this person's generosity also one
other thing they threw in which i think
is cool as hell
especially right now
this i know this cover anywhere is the
first edition
of the official xbox magazine 2001. it
was uh
right around the time would have been
november i think it should stay here
somewhere yeah november 2001 special
preview issue
it was right before the original xbox
came out it has dead or alive 3 halo
blood wake madden
tony hawk project gotham ah project
gotham i miss you
70 reasons why you have to get an xbox
this is going to be amazing to read
i might read this on a stream or
something so they also threw this in
which is incredibly cool so to try to
make me
feel a little bit more cool about having
this incredibly cool thing given to me
what i'm going to do is try to pay that
forward and do something
good with this so i've started a
campaign
which i will link in the description
below to try to raise money for relief
for the fires that are very much burning
across the west coast
of the united states right now i
certainly woke up with intense asthma
today
uh you've probably seen photos where the
sky is like red or orange in uh a lot of
the cities here
because this the fires are really bad
one of them started by a gender reveal
a text would have been fine karen but uh
i'm going to basically open it up so
that anyone who donates
any amount of money to my fundraising
campaign any amount can be a dollar
because i know that there are people who
can't necessarily afford this kind of
thing
is in the running to win uh an xbox one
from me an xbox one x obviously i will
also throw in a year of free game pass
and uh you know i get a lot of game code
so i'll just give you a bunch of games
for free as well in a whole little
package
what i need you to do if you would like
to be in the running to win this
is to when you donate um you can tell me
if you want me to sign it
uh i'm happy to do that i'm sure a lot
of people probably don't want that
on their xboxes but if you would like me
to do that i'm happy to do that and two
you'll just need to give me a way to
contact you
um for privacy reasons i would suggest
giving me a twitter or an instagram it's
just gonna need to be somewhere that you
have dms open so
on twitter you would need to have your
dms open i will have the
uh campaign open for a week
and then i will literally just put
everyone's names in a random generator
and we will pick
winners totally a random and then i will
reach out to them i'll give you about 48
hours to respond before i have to move
on to the next person and i will send
you
an xbox one x it will just be a a plain
black one
giving away two and uh game pass and a
whole bunch of games so
let's try to raise some money obviously
if you don't want an xbox it would be
awesome to have your help anyway
but this is what i i felt i should do
um in honor of this freaking incredible
gift
alrighty you guys those are the details
if i feel like i've left anything out
i'll leave it in the description i'm
alana thank you guys for watching
bye